just incredibly loud and I've never used
anything like it in my life it was it
was unbelievable it was quite shocking
actually didn't really know what to
think at the time
uh oh yeah
let's know that all children were safe
because of school nearby but uh yeah I
go I go past her every day practically
with the dog uh yeah being scary I
honestly didn't know what it was I I
thought maybe
I didn't know what it was I it sounded
like an earthquake of something like
that about it was just so loud it was
really loud very close-knit Community
yeah everybody knows everyone else
um shocking shocking but that it could
happen
just uh it makes you realize how
dangerous gas is and uh
shocked really